Narrator: From the cleaning crews
removing rubber from runways
and deicers ensuring planes are safe
for takeoff in the winter
to the hundreds of dedicated workers
that deep clean each train car
for one of the busiest
transit systems in the world,
we took a look at five cleanings
that happen behind the scenes
in order to keep the travel
industry running smoothly.
In the wintertime,
one of the biggest risks airlines face
is the buildup of ice on
the surface of an aircraft.
Ice impacts a plane's aerodynamics
and in extreme cases
can prevent a plane from creating lift.
This is Chris.
He's operating a
specialized deicing vehicle
that's worth half a million dollars.
Chris is a certified deicing
instructor for Delta Air Lines,
and he's been doing
this work for 25 years.
Chris and his team have one key goal
when temperatures drop below 50 degrees.
Chris: We have to have
all the ice and snow
off the airplane before
we can allow it to go out.
There's no room for screw-ups.
Narrator: This is a demanding job.
Deicers work in freezing
temperatures and extreme weather,
but that's not the only challenge.
They're also racing against the clock.
When flight schedules are packed,
Chris and his team might
have less than five minutes
to ensure an aircraft is
completely free of ice and snow
and is safe for takeoff.
Chris: The small airplanes we
can do in two to five minutes.
The wide-body airplanes,
10 minutes to a half an hour,
just depending on how
much snow is coming down
and how much was on the aircraft
when it was at the gate.
Narrator: If the time between deicing
and takeoff exceeds the holdover time,
after which the deicing
is no longer effective,
they have to start the entire
process all over again.
Chris: Sometimes we have
to deice it multiple times,
especially if there's a runway closure.
We'll deice the airplane,
and then they have to
close it for plowing.
At that point,
we'd have to re-deice the
airplane all over again,
and then the runway will be open,
and then they can take off.
Narrator: Preparations for winter begin
months before the snow hits the ground.
Each summer, Delta Air
Lines gathers its 400
senior deicing agents
from across the country
for a three-day boot camp.
They arrive at Minneapolis-St.
Paul International Airport
between July and September
to hone their skills and learn new ones.
Then the agents return
to their home airports
to teach others what they've learned.
In addition to the practical training,
Delta Air Line deicers must
pass a computer simulation
and courses in a classroom.
Chris: One of the reasons
we want to make sure
that we get all the
contaminants off of the wing
is so that it doesn't go
through the engine fan blades.
This is one of our engine
fan blades that was damaged
from ice coming off of a wing
and fouling out an engine fan blade.
It's a very real problem.
That's why we are all here
deicing the airplanes.
Narrator: Today, Chris
is on the deicing pad
leading a practical
training on an Airbus A220.
He starts with an inspection.
Chris: When we're doing
our initial inspection
of the aircraft for deicing purposes,
we're going to start with the radome
and see if we picked
up any descending icing
when the aircraft was landing,
as it's coming through the clouds.
We want to make sure that
nothing formed up there.
We also want to make sure
that before we do any deicing,
all the avionics bays are closed,
all the cargo doors are closed,
and then pay special
attention to our fuel panels
or the fuel cells
to see if we've got any
underwing frost forming.
Depending on the wind, of course,
if we have to shut the engines down
so we can get in closer, we can do that.
Obviously safety is always
going to be our number one.
OK, so we never want to spray
directly into the brakes,
and we never want to spray directly
into the suspension of the aircraft
because we don't want to
wash any of that grease off.
And if we do, we definitely want
to notify the crew immediately.
We definitely want to pay
attention to our nav lights
because that's where some of
the rime ice is going to form.
It's a good place to look for it.
If we find it there, then
it could be on the wing.
Make sense?
Perfect, all right.
Narrator: The deicing process
consists of several steps
and can happen either at the gate
or at a special deicing pad.
To start, pilots configure the
wings by lowering the flaps
and temporarily disabling the
aircraft's ventilation system.
Chris: So, the deice process is
very comparable to a car wash and a wax.
Typically in Minneapolis,
we'll start at the nose of the aircraft
and then work our way back,
spraying the fuselage
and then the wing and then the tail.
We usually do at least
a two-truck operation.
Sometimes if it's snowing real bad,
we'll have up to four trucks.
Narrator: The truck can lift the deicer
30 feet into the air,
where Chris uses a joystick
to control the nozzle
that sprays the deicing
fluid at high pressure.
Each truck has large
tanks that mix the liquids
to reach specific
chemical-to-water ratios.
Chris: You like that 2-by-4?
Half a million dollar
truck, and we use a 2-by-4
to hold these nozzles from spinning.
So yeah, this is where we
fill the truck with our water,
our type I, and then our type IV
anti-icing fluids filled here.
Narrator: Delta uses two
types of liquid for deicing.
Chris: We use propylene
glycol, type I fluid,
for deicing the aircraft.
That's the fluid that we
heat up to 180 degrees.
And then we'll use
Cryotech Polar Guard Xtend
for the type IV anti-icing.
Narrator: On an average
frosty day in Minneapolis,
deicers can use up to
2,000 gallons of fluid.
On a snowy day, they might need as much as
50,000 gallons.
Chris: The blend-to-mix ratio
depends on the outside air temp.
So what's actually deicing
or what's actually melting
the snow or the frost
is actually the heated water.
The reason that we add the
chemical to the heated water
is so it doesn't freeze to the airplane.
Narrator: The last step is
the most crucial of all:
making sure the airplane
stays deiced until takeoff.
Chris: The fluid lasts on the aircraft,
depending on the amount of
frozen precip that's coming down.
So if there is no precip coming down,
we just have to spray it off.
If it's currently snowing,
then we have to use the type IV.
So it's kind of like your car antifreeze.
The more antifreeze you put in,
the stronger the blend ratio is.
Narrator: Once a deicer
signs off on the plane,
the pilot will configure
the flight position,
taxi to the runway, and take off.
Chris: We can try and set up
as much trucks and overtime
and staffing for any given scenario,
but you never can tell. It's Minnesota.
Especially when we're
dealing with the weather.
Narrator: When the boot camp ends,
all the deicers return
to their home airports
to share what they've learned
and get ready for the upcoming winter.
But for the team here in Minneapolis,
one of the coldest cities
in the United States,
this is a year-round operation.
Chris: The most satisfying
part of the job is
the last flight of the
night that takes off safely.
You know, I don't mind
being outside in the winter.
I'm going to be outside either way.
Might as well be getting paid.
Narrator: So next time you board a flight
in the middle of winter
and see an orange liquid
sliding off the wing,
you'll know that someone
like Chris is out there
to make sure your plane is
ready to take off safely.
[Narrator] Every time a plane lands,
each tire leaves around
one and a half pounds
of rubber on the runway.
Tires are stationary until touchdown,
when sudden contact with the ground
causes friction,
quickly bringing them up to speeds
of more than 150 miles per hour
and producing temperatures
around 500 degrees Fahrenheit.
That temperature makes
the tread rubber melt
and bond to the runway
and lights that guide pilots.
The Airbus A380 is the
largest passenger plane
in the world and it has 22 tires.
That's over 30 pounds of
rubber lost per landing,
equivalent to the amount of rubber
in two of your car's tires.
So how does all of that
rubber get removed,
and what's so dangerous
about it building up on runways?
Mohammed: There is two things
you need to consider when we're talking
rubber removal from the runway.
There's the rubber removal
from the actual tarmac itself,
but the other process
is to remove the rubber
from the lights.
Narrator: At London's Heathrow Airport,
where Mohammed works,
an average of 650 planes
with 10 tires each
touchdown every single day.
That's 10,000 pounds of rubber daily.
A buildup in rubber
can make the surface of a runway smooth,
decreasing the friction needed to land.
This can impact braking and control
and increase the risk of hydroplaning
in wet conditions.
And runway lights used to guide takeoff,
landing, and taxiing, especially at night
and in low visibility conditions,
are dimmed by the melted
rubber bonding to them.
Within the United States,
the Federal Aviation
Administration recommends
that rubber deposition be checked weekly
for any airport with at
least 210 daily landings.
The process for checking rubber buildup
isn't as simple as
checking for skid marks,
and it requires the use of specialized
tests and instruments.
Mohammad: So for the runway, we have something
called the friction test.
It's like a machine that has a wheel
and someone will drive down the runway
and that wheel will come down
and it'll actually measure
how much friction there is on the runway.
The key to our runway is you want it
to have a lot of friction.
You don't want it to be slippery at all.
So that measurement of how much friction
that wheel feels on the
surface of the runway
will tell our teams when to go out there
to remove the rubber.
Now, to do that, we have
specialized machinery,
which is like a massive truck
with a Hoover on top of it.
And so it's high pressure
water, basically,
but very hot and it blasts the tarmac
and then it just sucks up
everything that comes off it.
Narrator: And then there's removal
of rubber from the lights.
Landing technology alone isn't enough
for pilots to bring planes in safely.
Mohammad: Of course, they use ILS systems,
they use the Instrument Landing System,
when coming into land,
but they still need a visual reference.
So from a safety perspective,
the pilots physically
won't be able to see those lights.
And I once spoke to a pilot
who was flying in from Scandinavia.
And I remember I always go to the pilots
and speak to them about
this stuff afterwards
because I want to get their perspective.
And I said to him, "What's
it like to fly a plane
at an airport and land
a plane at an airport
which doesn't maintain
its lights very well?"
He said, "It's like trying to fly a plane
into a black hole."
So for the lights themselves,
we do a test where we measure
how much light output
comes out of the lights.
So we have this trailer
that hooks on the back of a car
and the sensors on the
back of this trailer
will tell you exactly how much light
is coming out of every single light.
And then you get all that
data and you can tell
which lights have rubber on them.
So the lights are really important
and they need to be bright.
So to do that, we have another machine,
which uses dry soda and it has somebody
on the back of the lance and they go
from one light to another
and they point this thing at it
and they shoot powder, this soda powder,
at the actual lens of the light
and they get rid of all the rubber
that is on those lights
Narrator: From when the last plane
takes off at night
to when the first plane
takes off in the morning,
there's a small window of time.
Mohammad: Our runways need to
close, so we need to wait
until the last plane departs,
and then after the last plane departs
that's when our teams can come on.
So if you wanted to clean
every single light on the runway,
you can't really do it all in one night,
because there's that many of them.
So for the lights themselves,
we remove it at least twice per week.
This is something that people
don't ever really think about
but there's a whole team of people
whose responsibility is to make sure
that these runways are cleared.
And actually, people benefit from this job
all the time because the only way
that they're able to go on holiday
and enjoy the world is by using
these strips of tarmac called the runways.
Narrator: The Tokyo Metro system is famous
for being one of the cleanest
subway systems in the world.
It transports an average of
about 6 million people daily,
and maintaining that reputation
takes both an extensive amount
of operational organization
and a ton of manpower.
Narrator: This is Takayuki,
a cleaning supervisor at
the rail yard in Ayase.
He's worked for Tokyo
Metro for almost 41 years,
and it's his job to make sure
the trains are cleaned thoroughly.
The cleaning staff's
approach is straightforward
but uncompromising: whatever Tokyo Metro's
millions of daily passengers
touch must be cleaned.
Today, they're cleaning the train cars
at the Ayase rail yard,
which they do every 15 days.
The cleaners take careful measures
to ensure each nook and cranny is cleaned.
Then we'll head to the
Ginza-itchome Station,
located in one of the
busiest shopping areas
in Tokyo, Japan,
where they clean the
station top to bottom.
There are 41 trains on the
Tokyo Metro Chiyoda Line.
The team cleans three
to four trains a day.
Once a train comes into the rail yard,
cleaners start by picking
up any trash they see.
It takes four workers
to clean the exterior.
It's all done by hand, and cleaners start
by hosing it down with water
and then using brushes
to scrub it with soap.
Narrator: If the stain does not come off
with a brush and soap,
then they use a pad to scrub it off.
Next, they rinse off all the soap.
Meanwhile, other staffers
clean the interior.
It takes 10 workers, and they
start at the top of the car
and work their way down to the bottom.
Narrator: The first step
is to clean the area
where advertisements are placed.
Then they clean the luggage
racks, and then the wall area.
They use rags and dusters
to clean each part.
Narrator: Cleaners then tackle the floors
and start by mopping.
They also use sticks to clean crevices
near the entrance of each door.
Twice a year they wax the
floors of each train car.
They remove all the old
wax with a polisher,
and then they let it dry.
Once it's dry, they
apply two coats of wax.
It takes about an hour and a half
from the time the wax is removed
to the time the new wax dries.
Narrator: Altogether, it takes workers
a little over an hour
to clean the trains inside and out.
Once the cleaning is complete,
Takayuki begins his inspection.
Narrator: Once Takayuki
approves the cleaning,
the trains return to service,
ready to transport millions
of passengers all over again.
Inside the Ginza-itchome Station,
Chikako and Kenji work to
clean the station daily.
Narrator: Kazuhiro has been
working for Tokyo Metro
since he was 18.
He got his train license at 20
and drove trains until he was 57.
He leads the team responsible
for the cleaning and security
for this station and a few others.
There are nine Tokyo Metro train lines
and 180 stations that provide service
to the greater Tokyo area.
Narrator: The escalator handrails
are a high-touch surface
within the station,
and Chikako takes extra
care to wipe the belt
with wet washcloths.
She rides the escalators up and down
until they are all clean.
Narrator: Chikako is also responsible
for the dirtiest job of the day,
cleaning the two restrooms
in the Ginza-itchome Station.
The main cleanings happen once a day.
She has been doing this
work for the past 10 years.
Narrator: The first thing Chikako does
is check for any large pieces of trash.
If there are none, she sets up a fan
and leaves it on throughout
the cleaning process.
Efficiency is one of the
key parts of her job,
and the fan allows the
bathroom to dry quickly,
so as not to disrupt any
customers who may need to use it.
Narrator: Chikako sticks
the ozone-machine hose
down the toilet and turns it on.
Then she scrubs each toilet by hand
to make sure it's clean
for the next customer.
She also cleans the walls.
It's important that she's
using the right tools
for each space, so as not
to cross-contaminate areas.
She uses a red dust cloth to clean
areas from the knees down,
which is called the "contamination zone,"
and a green one for "clean zones,"
which are areas above the knees,
such as mirrors and sinks.
Narrator: Chikako is also
responsible for cleaning
the barrier between the
platform and the train doors.
The top part is cleaned daily,
while the lower part
is cleaned once a week.
The staff makes sure the
station platforms and walkways
are clean for customers.
They do cleanings with brooms every day,
but they also use a
machine to clean the floors
twice a month.
The machine works by sprinkling
water onto the floor,
scrubbing with a brush,
and then collecting the
dirty water with a squeegee.
This way, there is no water left behind
and no slippery floors.
Narrator: Kenji also goes around daily
with a shoulder vacuum
and manually vacuums up
any trash and dust he comes across,
especially in hard-to-reach areas.
Narrator: Japan has a
long history with cleaning
and cleanliness that persists today.
Narrator: Now we head off to sea
and climb aboard one of the
world's largest cruise ships,
Royal Caribbean's Symphony of the Seas,
to watch how workers deal with
millions of pounds of water,
food, and dry waste every year.
Narrator: This cruise ship is
basically a floating city.
And just like in a normal city,
all its residents produce a lot of trash.
But there aren't any garbage trucks here
to scoop it up and take it away.
We're at sea, obviously.
And since waste can't and shouldn't
just be dumped in the ocean,
well, what do cruise
ships do with all of it?
This is something the industry's
been dealing with for years.
Reporter: Carnival Cruise
Line is coming clean
about polluting oceans.
Narrator: Princess Cruises
was fined $40 million
in 2016 for illegal dumping,
and Carnival got hit with
a $20 million fine in 2019
for disposing of plastic
waste in the ocean.
Stewart Chiron: Carnival
Corporation's issues
really brought the need
for better technology
so that these ships can
operate more efficiently.
Narrator: Cruise lines have
been working on systems
to purify water and deal
with waste inside ships.
Chiron: Up until now, these types
of options weren't available.
Narrator: All this new tech was built
into Royal Caribbean's
largest and newest ship,
Symphony of the Seas.
The company says it's
a zero-landfill ship,
which means it uses
everything from recycling
to water filtration to
deal with its own waste.
And this guy's in charge of making sure
no single water bottle is unaccounted for.
Alex Mago: Welcome to
waste and recycling center.
Narrator: We're down on deck two,
a secret, crew-only area of the ship.
Crew members check all
the ship's trash cans
for recyclables and bring them down here
for Alex's team to handle.
Despite being the only waste facility
on this massive ship,
it's surprisingly quiet.
Alex said the busiest
time is in the morning,
when things are unpackaged for the day.
Mago: This is the waste
streams that we have.
Every waste stream has its
own way of handling it.
Narrator: There are
separate teams to deal with
each incoming recyclable:
glass, cardboard, plastic, and metal.
Mago: This is our incinerator room.
So, we have two incinerators, one and two.
This area is manned 24 hours a day.
We have 10 crew members
who are working here,
five in the morning and
five in the evening.
Narrator: Crew members
separate glass into colors:
green, brown, and white.
[glass clinking]
Mago: This is the byproduct of it
after we crush it.
Narrator: They can process upwards
of 13,000 pounds of glass
for a weeklong cruise.
All the small glass
pieces are stored in bins
until the ship docks.
Plastic goes through
this massive compactor.
Even though the ship's
gotten rid of plastic straws,
it still relies on bottled water because,
for health and safety reasons,
no cruise ship is allowed
to have water fountains.
So, every week,
they crush about
528 gallons of water bottles.
Mago: We are compacting
the cardboard over there.
Narrator: Throughout the
day, cardboard is stacked up
in this machine, called a baler.
Once it's full, it's all
compressed into bundles.
And used aluminum cans,
well, they're sent through this baler.
The machine squeezes
them down into big cubes,
which are then stored in a fridge
just off the waste room.
Mago: This area is actually for the items
that can produce smell, the garbage.
Narrator: And the smell
could get pretty bad.
The waste is stored for up
to seven days at a time,
until the ship docks back in Miami,
where all the plastic, aluminum, paper,
and glass go to recycling
partner facilities.
In 2018, Royal
Caribbean recycled
43.7 million pounds of waste.
And any rebates earned from
these recycling programs
go back to the employee retirement fund.
The cruise line is hoping that it's a nice
incentive for employees
to bring recycling down
from their own crew cabins.
So, what about things
that can't get recycled?
For example, food.
Every week, the ship loads up
600,000 pounds of provisions.
But for the food that's not eaten,
well, the company had to figure out
how to get rid of all of that, too.
Each one of the
ship's restaurants
and 36 kitchens has
its own suction drain.
Chefs and waiters keep food
scraps in separate buckets.
Then, once they've gotten enough,
they place it all in this special drain.
All the food waste ends up in one big pipe
that runs through the entire ship.
And that pipe leads to what's known
as the hydro-processor.
Mago: Those pipes over there,
so, this is where
the food waste is passing through.
This is being processed through here.
Narrator: This machine
has a bunch of tiny layers
of mesh to break down the food.
Mago: It's being stored in our tank.
We have two tanks of
comminuted food waste.
Narrator: And the final step?
Incineration.
Now, let's talk about your toilet waste.
Yep, we're gonna go there.
It's all a part of the
water-treatment system on board,
controlled from the engineering room.
Narrator: Water is divided
into two categories:
gray water, from sinks,
laundries, and drains,
and black water.
That includes everything from the galleys
and your toilets, including your urine.
Narrator: The purification
system purifies the water
to a point above the US federal standard,
which is almost safe to drink.
Narrator: Anything that can't be recycled
or reused on board goes to what's known
as a waste-to-energy facility.
Now, we didn't get to
see it for ourselves,
but Royal Caribbean said
"heat or gas from the waste is collected
and converted to energy."
Chiron: It's definitely
within their best interests
to be the most environmentally friendly,
because it significantly can
reduce the waste on board,
the weight that they have
to carry, the fuel usage,
and it reduces their
operational expenses as well.
Narrator: And after one week at sea,
the recycling gets cleared out,
incoming provisions are brought on board,
and the crew prepares the ship
to start the process all over again.
Narrator: Every year, tens of thousands of people
attend Burning Man in
Nevada's Black Rock Desert,
and many of them rent cars, RVs,
and trucks to attend the festival.
But Burning Man can get messy,
and the desert's playa dust
that collects on vehicles
is high in alkaline,
which can corrode a car's metal
and cause long-term damage
if not thoroughly cleaned.
Car-rental providers in the area,
like Enterprise Rent-A-Car,
brace for Burning Man each year.
In a typical year, detailers expect
to find rental cars returned
coated in layers of dried desert sand.
But this year's extreme weather
left vehicles in even
worse condition than usual,
which meant that detailers
like Miguel and his team
had their work cut out for them.
These cars are really, really bad.
They got covered with
sand, like, everywhere.
Like, sand everywhere.
The interior, the outside, the engine.
This year it rained,
so this is a different kind of sand now.
So it's going to be a little
bit harder than usual.
Narrator: Miguel and his
team must pay close attention
to the details when cleaning
the mud-battered rental returns.
Whether the weather is extreme or not,
any dust or debris that
settles into the crevices
of a vehicle has the potential to discolor
or damage a car if the cleaning process
is not done properly.
Today, Miguel and his team
are focused on detailing
a white Jeep Gladiator
from start to finish.
And if they do a thorough job,
the Jeep will look brand new
for its next group of renters.
The team begins by assessing
the scale of the job at hand,
starting with the car's exterior.
All of the rental returns first go through
the automatic car wash in
Enterprise's cleaning bays.
But if a vehicle is returned
significantly muddier than most,
it might also need an
initial pressure wash
to loosen the mud and any other debris.
After passing through the
automatic wash the first time,
the muddiest Burning Man cars might need
a bit more elbow grease.
For this, Miguel uses a
brush with a long handle
to loosen any remaining dirt.
After detailing by hand
with the scrub brush,
Miguel does another round
of pressure washing,
then decides if the
Jeep needs an extra run
through the automatic wash.
So, right now we just ran
the car through the car wash.
It looks OK.
We just gotta wait and see
how it looks after it dries.
But next, we're going to do the inside
and we're going to vacuum
and do the panels and windows.
Narrator: But before they can start
cleaning the interior,
Miguel needs to check under the hood
to inspect the car's engine,
which may also have been
coated in fine alkaline sand
from the Black Rock Desert,
often referred to as playa dust.
This stubborn sand is made up
of remnants from the prehistoric lake bed
that predated the Black Rock Desert.
The dust itself is extremely fine,
which means it can settle into
a vehicle's smallest grooves
and crevices inside and out.
The dust's high-alkaline
pH is also corrosive
and can damage upholstery,
plastics, and even electronics.
Burning Man organizers are well aware
of the playa dust's
potential risk to vehicles,
as many festivalgoers this
year learned firsthand.
The official Burning Man
website suggests festivalgoers
wash their cars immediately
upon returning home
before the alkaline dust has a chance
to damage their vehicles.
It recommends using an air compressor
to blow the dust off the engine.
In extremely dirty cases,
pressure washing may be
the most effective method
of deep cleaning, but this
requires a level of equipment
and expertise that's best left
to trained professionals,
like Miguel and his crew.
When they're ready to clean the interiors,
Miguel removes the Jeep's floor mats.
He scrubs a detergent
deep into the mats' fibers
and uses the pressure washer
to rinse off the suds.
Finally, he runs an
extractor over the floor mats
to remove excess moisture.
Next, the team gets to work
cleaning every interior surface.
This phase includes deep
cleaning the upholstery
and interior doors and
detailing the dashboard,
center console, gearbox,
and steering wheel.
They dry-vacuum loose playa sand
before applying cleaning solutions,
deodorizers, and disinfectants.
So, right now, this is with the thing
that we use for the interior.
It's a multipurpose solution that we use.
We're going to use it on the seats,
hopefully help us with all the stains
and the sand and the dirt.
Narrator: They use small
handheld dust brushes
to loosen ground-in dirt
and microfiber cloths to wipe
down the hard plastic surfaces
until they're spotless and dry.
This sand is different because
it's kind of like chalk.
It sticks on the panels
and the car and the tires.
So it's a different kind of sand.
That's why we gotta use
these special chemicals
and the pressure washer.
Narrator: The last step
of the detailing process
is drying the floors
and seats of the Jeep.
Then the Jeep is nearly restored
to its pre-festival state
and is ready for any finishing touches
before its big reveal.
We just finished the interior.
We did the carpets,
the seats, and the plastics.
Right now we're going to do
pressure washing one more time.
There's still some sand.
There's dirt under the tires.
So, we finally finished
with the Burning Man car.
So if you can follow me,
I'll show you how it looks now.
So as you can see, we cleaned
all the mud, all the sand,
all the dirt in the tires.
We basically shampooed the carpet,
the seats,
and also the driver.
We also cleaned the
grille, the windshield.
We got all the bugs.
This car, as you can
see, looks good as new.
Took us a couple hours. It's finally done.
I don't think anybody's going to notice
that it went to Burning Man.
That's my opinion.
I hope the customer agrees with me.